hi my name is David Byrne I feel
carefree and buoyant about being Conan
O'Brien's friend oh my God now is that
really how you feel or is you on some
kind of medication
no no I haven't had medication in quite
a while hours it's been hours
[Laughter]
well first of all I want to start by
asking you I am here at these serious
studios in Midtown New York did you ride
a bike here yes I did
and did you in fact strike that woman
with your bike
um no I'm just curious because I know
that you are an avid biker I'm a biker I
love riding a bicycle a friend of mine
uh his my favorite saying is that he has
is no no one's ever had a bad day on a
bike
um but
is it practical here in New York City
can you get around pretty well relying
on the bike I can get around really well
I live in Manhattan Manhattan's not that
big of an island and usually most of my
meetings and work are below Central Park
let's say yep
so it's pretty easy I've gotten used to
it I stay in the bike Lanes I mostly
stop at red lights
I've uh never had a serious accent so
I'm right very lucky about that yeah I
wouldn't Advocate and say oh just you've
never done it before okay just jump on a
bike and get in the traffic right yeah I
would not I would say that to someone I
didn't like
I have an idea yes if you see some guy
coming right at you going the wrong way
stick your hand out but you know with
the e-bikes now It's Tricky I don't know
if you have that but I when I'm in
Manhattan now walking around uh there
are these people that are delivering
food and they'll go buy on a bike I
can't even hear that's going 60 miles an
hour in the bike lane I don't know if
you've encountered that I have certainly
encountered that sometimes going the
wrong way so when you're crossing the
street or whatever you don't expect them
to kind of Blindside you right it's you
know there's a little bit of an
enforcement problem going on there right
well
um I I wanted to start talking to you
and I know that there are unusual
circumstances if you're growing up which
is you lived in Scotland Scotland for
how many years not very many I think the
family all left when I was two moved to
Canada
moved to Suburban Baltimore when I was
around seven or eight so but you had a
Scottish accent for a while oh yeah yeah
and yeah the kids couldn't understand me
and so I would think what's going to
make someone in elementary school feel
more like an outsider than having a uh a
thick Scottish accent that must have
been uh I mean first of all that is
something that right away
if you're a kid and you're sensitive you
feel you must have felt like I need to
overcome this how do what do I do how do
I fit in
yeah and kids at that age they want to
they want to fit in they want to be like
everyone else
there's not like oh I'm my own person
I'm yeah I do my own thing I talk my own
way I do kids are not ready for that
right uh so I'm sure I lost the accent
within you know a couple of years or
something but right away you know that
I didn't talk the same way as the other
kids right my parents eat holding their
knives and forks at the same time uh
animals
[Music]
you're eating blood sausage yes you
can't have anyone come over yes we
called it black pudding yes
so I would think I mean again I do think
sometimes although these things can be
painful when you're a kid
um
being too well adjusted
comes with a price and I think feeling a
little bit like an outsider maybe has
some advantages uh when it comes to
maybe you I don't know having an
interior life thinking what can I find
that's mine and then that turns out to
be music
yes music is very healing for a person
who feels a little bit of an outsider
trying to figure things out can't quite
fit in music yeah the rock music what
it's all like wow
there's people out there kind of like me
where are they right they're not here
but I know they're out there they're not
they can hear them on the radio uh what
instruments because I'm obviously guitar
but there are other instruments that you
dabbled with as a as a kid uh
if you can call a tape recorder an
instrument yeah you can okay then I did
that my parents were uh
not
like Showbiz pushy but they were
supportive so my dad had a tape recorder
and I wanted to start playing with it
and doing things I'd heard about like
cutting up tape and rearranging the
order of the stuff on the tapes and
editing and doing all that kind of thing
and uh so he you know let me do that
yeah uh so
supportive in that way it was really
nice and I think you dabbled in
violin accordion did you play accordion
I had a friend who played accordion I
played violin and then at some point uh
I connected with a friend and
he played accordion I played violin and
ukulele and we uh played on the street
sometimes and I did a little bit of uh
well you might call it acrobatics mainly
I just stood on one leg
you stood on one leg Yeah as you played
yeah as I played and looked at looked at
this that's very Jethro Tull he used to
stand on one leg in uh I mean Aqualung
uh exactly
um what am I think of Ian Ian Anderson
is that his name yes would stand on one
leg and play uh in this very dramatic
pose and play his uh flute solos I think
my gesture was meant to be a little more
ironic like
look at what I'm look like what I'm
doing look look isn't this amazing and
yet I was really just standing with on
one foot
well clearly you're active all
right in the 70s at cbgb's people were
like you got to see this guy he stands
on one leg
music I don't know but I haven't
listened to it